this young lady comes up and we take a
photo and then she says I just have to
let you know that I was introduced to
you by a guy who used to make me suck
his nipples while jacking him off
there's zero sexual anything coming from
my nipples
that is in any way related to anything
sexual hold up really so you're saying
you're saying you could get your nipple
uh absolutely
what why are you like someone it would
feel like someone's sucking on my elbow
is that from diving you just get like
maybe from running I've just shaved
every nerve oh yeah yeah
yeah you've got foreskin on your nipples
you got to pull them back to get to the
good part little pink earlobes right
here